signor maestà ma lei si curate mio
figlio è pronto no perché io possa
tenere ancora un anno a casa non è un
problema non lo so maestra lo vedo perso
ho paura che mi hai mandato analizzato i
toni sembra ieri che lasciava adesso
mietto pronto a spiccare il volo amore
mamma sta qui e non me ne vado stai
tranquillo poi tesoro tutto bene tu che
sezione altro piccolo ma delle
coccinelle e viene cavallucci marini
miei io sono tranquillissimo guarda due
minuti e me ne vado questo distacco nome
passare per niente male davvero vita mia
scopri il mondo colora la vita con i
pennarelli gaeta ha comprato mamma con
tanto amore maestra nello zainetto gli
ho messo la pasta al forno e soggetto
preferito mamma maestra un'ultima cosa
kakà non è affatto quindi mi raccomando
vi faccio sapere parte la fattura se la
fa molle perché ha avuto male al pancino
la giuria mia va bene l'ho sentito
piangere maestra maria morariu steinmann
amaro lo svago che non ti può portare ad
esso si portò a casa mamma vieni